I think this ends today I think you
commit to yourself and to him and to
everybody around you this is the last
time we speak this the last time I talk
to you I block you on everything I drop
everything you are out of my
life and for good you might have to move
Apartments you might have to do all quit
your job I don't care what you have to
do you are going to drown in this this
is the moment when the alcoholic takes
all the bottles and pours them down the
sink you got to walk
away and then you got to look around at
the burn down landscape of your life and
say I need some people to help me
rebuild this thing can it be rebuilt
100% but the lying and the deception and
the secrets and
the just utter violation over years of
your own Integrity of your this person's
poor wife and kids all of it stops today